la sortie de caisse qu'on a encore fait
au mon dieu c'est la suite d'un film qui
a été un énorme succès avec notamment
christian clavier bas côté si vous
n'avez pas encore vu le film je vous
propose de regarder un extrait de la
bande annonce il ya des images et
pourtant il fait noir très noir même si
les noirs comme un sénégalais c'est vrai
qu'ils et puis un petit diamant de sang
noir et plus fort c'est la puissance
africaine
très très noir quand même alors
s'interroge non pas du tout c'est mon
pad m6 en blu ray très blanc début que
je pensais que tu es mon temps juste un
constat se vérifie et on en a encore le
droit de constater d'un pays je constate
alors vous l'avez compris dans ce film
c'est la fille de christian clavier qui
a un enfant dont le père est noire de
toute évidence et on est parti de ceux
de la sortie de ce film pour se poser la
question dans le figaro magazine de ce
week-end plutôt encore rire de tout le
constat de ce dossier que vous pourrez
découvrir in extenso
c'est qu'en fait il ya quand même de
plus en plus de d'autocensure est-ce que
c'est aussi votre avis bertrand perrier
moi je crois que ayant vu la scène que
vous n'êtes pas c'est ma conclusion est
on peut rire de tout ici c'est drôle
c'était presque défilé et je viens
d'économiser 15 euros hab seul souffle
et je vous en remercie tous feu adrien
matouba donc ça le film fera pas
forcément le voir non voilà j'ai grillé
15 euros et 2 heures très bien on a
compris a pris à tous et c'est d'abord
ça vous fait rire cet extrait est un
exposé sur la qualité du film tel que le
sujet dépasse le socio comme mon
émission c'est la parole est libre
ça dépasse le lui même j'en conviens
volontiers
donc on peut dire d'être là est-ce qu'on
peut encore rire de tout c'est la
question qu'on se pose ce week end une
question qu'on pose beaucoup j'ai
l'impression nous à marjah monde avait
fait un numéro de fin d'année sur voilà
les
qu'est-ce qui serait accepter ou pas
accepter aujourd'hui alors moi j'ai
toujours un peu de mal avec les gens qui
disent on ne peut plus rien dire et
alors qu'ils sont en train de tout dire
justement il me semble que on peut rire
de tout mais qu'on est sûr en tout cas
de se retrouver confronté à d
indignation que ce soit par le biais des
réseaux sociaux des médias
voilà je pense que si on se penche en
tout cas sur la loi on peut encore tout
dit rire de tout en tout cas pas moins
qu'il ya 30 ans par contre effectivement
par le biais de twitter notamment dont
on surestime il me semble beaucoup
l'importance des rangs forcément on va
avoir des gens qui vont s'indigner de
manière plus ou moins légitimes mais
peut-être que l'on devrait - s'attarder
sur ces ordinations
on continue avec cette question très
simple peut-on rire de tout
quel est votre avis rashed bin oui je
revends ce qui a été dit c'est à dire
que alors peut-être que d'un point de
vue judiciaire
on a cette même liberté d'expression
mais le tribunal des réseaux sociaux le
tribunal médiatique
n'empêche quand même de plus en plus
c'est à dire qu'il ya de plus en plus de
sujets la liste ne fait que s'allonger
sur lesquels il est devenu extrêmement
difficile de rire on pense bien sûr à la
sphère texte on pense aux blackface etc
et c'est un petit peu paradoxal parce
que les mêmes qui se disent ou qui se
disait je ne sais pas à quel point il
faut conjuguer le verbe charlie charlie
hebdo sont les premiers à brandir la
pancarte de l'indignation
dès lors que le rire earth leur
idéologie leurs dogmes ou leur
sensibilité propre
donc non je pense que c'était une forme
de come ca de tyrannie de l'émotion à
laquelle s'ajoute une position un
certain nombre de communautés de
minorités qui utilisent justement
le rire l'indignation qu'ils peuvent y
avoir pour pour militer dire que c'est
un outil aujourd'hui un outil politique
un outil d'existence pour un certain
nombre de communautés ou d'associations
qui veulent exister dans le débat public
par exemple ce que vous appelez ce qu'on
appelle en anglais blackface c'est à
dire le fait de se grimer en noir quand
on est blanc c'est considéré aujourd'hui
comme une forme de racisme que donc on
ne peut plus être un moyen d'un cran
alors avec à chaque fois des vernis des
termes plus ou moins sociologique
universitaire l'appropriation culturelle
sms avec déguisements alors après ça ça
dépend bon mais où on met la frontière
mais en tout cas il ya pas mal de sujets
comme ça sur laquelle il est extrêmement
difficile d'avancer et au risque
d'enfoncer des portes ouvertes
on sait très bien aujourd'hui que des
humoristes qui ont officié dans les
années 40 50 60 70 80
aujourd'hui ne pourrait plus le sketch
de 2 à bâle le sketch de coluche sur le
viol alors non j'aimerais beaucoup
j'aimerais beaucoup traversée à bord
rationnelle mais peut-être vous avez
raison mais vous avez raison mais mais
j'en veux j'en veux pour illustration
alors voilà les la sphère la ferté ex
qui est assez importante et une
indignation qui a été impressionnant à
la tête en avançant ce qui est
intéressant
effectivement le spectacle de gaspard
proust c'est absolument horrible parce
qu'il dit des choses et des choses
atroces qui évidemment du deuxième degré
mais c'est sur les noirs sur les juifs
les homosexuels tout le monde tout le
monde en prend pour son grade mais mais
vous n'avez aucune diffusion publique de
tout ça c'est que ça n'est ni seul
plateau de télévision ni sur les nids
sur les radios ni sur les disques vous
parliez de la sphère texte rachel
bidasses alors tech c'est cet humoriste
qui officiait sur sur france 2 pour une
émission qui s'appelle les amours je
crois je vais tout vous dire je la
regarde pas tous les jours mais
donc il cet humoriste en novembre 2017
est invité sur une autre une autre
émission sur une autre chaîne de
télévision et on invite à faire une
blague et voilà la blague
j'ai super sensible attente les deux
allaient tirer cela on le met du plomb
alors à la suite de cette blague ou
supposé tel texte donc a été viré de son
poste à france télévisions et puis je
voudrais faire la comparaison avec une
chronique tenus par l'humoriste daniel
morin c'était sur france inter le 27
septembre dernier je vous en laisse
juste deux trois phrases et il fait
allusion à une journaliste qui est une
consoeur de valeurs actuelles charlotte
d'ornellas ce qui est habituellement
classé à droite et voilà ce qu'il dit
sur france inter le matin du 27
septembre
les petites cateau d'extrême droite ça
m'excite tu me plais charlotte j'ai
envie qu'on fasse des petits jeux
coquins ça continue comme ça sur ce
registre orduriers je vous fais grâce
des détails
tu consultes sera et tuborg le rat nous
ferons amour bestialement comme deux
bergers allemands
rongé par le stupre et la luxure voilà
vannes et morat était encore ce matin
sur france inter pour sa chronique à ma
connaissance il n'a fait l'objet ni de
remontrance ni de la moindre critique
d'où ma question en bertrand perrier est
ce que c'est plus facile de faire
l'humour quand on sait sur des gens
d'extrême droite que quand on est sur
les femmes battues
j'ai ligne droite je retire c'est que je
viens de dire puisque charlotte
d'ornellas qui fut journaliste
conservatrice et dans ma bouche c'est
vraiment pas un propos désobligeants
donc le terme d'extrême droite n'a pas
lieu d'être ici non je ne sais pas après
c'est une question de curseur de la
liberté d'expression objectivement la
blague de texte est considérablement
c'est navrant frais ça pour qu'il sorte
de malaise est effroyable je lui dis pas
que ce que dit daniel morin est beaucoup
plus élégant soyons tout à fait clair
ce que je crois c'est que moi je crois
vraiment à la liberté d'expression et et
d'ailleurs la jurisprudence est vraiment
très très larges très souple dès lors
que son temps question des débats
d'intérêt général
malgré tout blessé pour blesser voilà il
faut vraiment avoir énormément de talent
pour pouvoir blessés ou pour pouvoir
tenir des propos grinçant sans être
juste vulgaire et blessant quand même si
vous avez le sentiment qu'il ya un peu
un deux poids deux mesures ou pas oui
bah l'illustration vous en avez donnée
est flagrante parce que quand même
d'un côté il y en a un qui fait une
blague douteuse effectivement pas très
amusante sur sur les femmes et qui est
immédiatement sanctionné et il y en a un
autre qui s'est quasiment apparaissent
qu'un appel au viol si on veut retirer
le caractère éventuellement humoristique
de ce qu'il dit et pour le coup lui il
n'a rien les deux étant sur le service
public un travaillé à france télévisions
et l'autre à france inter
exactement mais c'est là où pour revenir
à au bon dieu on se rend compte que
c'est difficile de faire rire
non mais il faut revenir au bond et fait
toujours rien c'est difficile de faire
rire sur des sujets sensibles et au fond
c'est là où qu'est-ce qu'on a encore
fait au bon dieu peut se rapprocher un
peu de rabbi jacob c'est à dire que
arrivée quelles que soient les qualités
ou pas du film je prends cette règle que
je devrais me regarde
mais arrivé à faire rire sur au fond du
racisme puisque dans le film chacun et
racisme c'est qu'aujourd'hui un sacré
exploit ce qu'un noir asiatique un juif
de tout le monde et chacun du mal de
l'autre de leur théâtre
absolument rachel vinasse jeu de là à
interdire quand même je pense qu'on
franchirait une ligne extrêmement
dangereuse c'est dire
qu est-ce qu comment on va les
sanctionner une déchéance de nationalité
pour ceux qui seraient allés trop loin
ou qui sont pas drôles on a le droit en
fait de ne pas être drôle c'est pas puni
par la loi
exactement sinon je serais la première
condamnez moi la blague le texte ne m'a
pas du tout choquée je suis pas très
sensible à son humour mais je
connaissais déjà cette blague je l'avais
déjà entendu par des amis etc
ça ne m'avait pas choquer plus que ça
donc ça je pense qu'il faut faire
oui oui bien sûr mais en foot il a été
viré et vous l'avez vous l'avez très
bien précisé il a été viré alors qu'il
ne s'agissait même pas de son émission
mais d'un exercice de promotion de son
spectacle on en pense ce qu'on veut et
je crois qu'il ya le choix qu'ils
tournent vers vers les prud'hommes et
avec de bons avocats il est fort à
parier qu'ils gagnent d'accord moi je
dis on été arrêtés prison maintenant si
on veut mettre un petit peu de morale
dans l'humour ce qui est un exercice
extrêmement délicat
plutôt que de dire est-ce qu'on peut
rire de tout c'est plutôt est ce que
tout le monde peut rire de tout c'est à
dire que je crois que quand on est par
exemple un pédophile et qu'on fait des
blagues sur des enfants
ou quand on a on a un antisémite on fait
des blagues sur les juifs ce n'est pas
drôle
pourquoi parce que là l'humour est
dévoyée parce que là il a un but qui est
quasiment militant politique est là en
effet c'est plus drôle
ensuite quand une personne lambda fait
une blague qui tombe pas à l'eau
mais quand même très difficile de le
condamner ou alors dans ce cas là on
utilise les voies que nous offre la
france et nos institutions
on se retourne derrière on se trouve
devant un tribunal et on présente la
faire tout simplement
ce sera le mot de la fin merci beaucoup
à tous les quatre merci de nous avoir
suivis point de vue c'est fini pour
cette semaine mais on vous retrouve avec
joie lundi prochain même heure même
endroit avec une animation toujours au
top niveau
bon week-end
[Musique]